[Music]
these guys are only seven weeks old but
when they get to full growth they're
jaguars but these are these are jaguars
the biggest cat in north america when
they're adults they can actually crush
your skull with their jaws and that's in
fact how they kill their prey let's see
that when can they come back and crush
me you know we'll bring them back in a
year and then we'll see how that works
in one year i will be killed on the air
by leopards yeah well actually they're
not leopards they're jaguars
i wasn't even listening i'm sorry
i'm more about making the joke than
listening to you instruct us uh they're
beautiful you say they're how many weeks
they're about seven weeks old they're
sisters and what most people don't
realize is that you know the black
panther the animal is not an actual
species it's just the melanistic form
this little girl right here same exact
animal as this it's just that she has
the dark color pattern if you look
really closely you can see
[Laughter]
she likes you
this is my tiger beat spread right here
let's
you should get one of those to use as a
makeup applicator oh wait no yeah a
powder puff okay hold it right there i
don't know how to do this you don't just
hold it just like that i fed my children
frozen pizza when they were born
they ate it
yeah they make horrible noises but but
the thing is is that these guys actually
live in the u.s they sometimes show up
in arizona and you know the national
wildlife they live they're found they're
not found in the united states believe
it or not these guys used to be found
throughout the whole southern part of
the the country hundreds of years ago we
wiped them out we destroyed their
habitat but they now live in central
south america and mexico and
occasionally make it up into arizona but
you know they're endangered and
endangered they're immediately deported
yeah well yeah sometimes
that's not right
but yeah the national wildlife
federation is all about protecting our
wildlife we could use as much help as
possible so hopefully you know people
will see these critters and want to
support our cause look at this one go
she's like at a sorority party she's
just
she's going to town on this
our little sister good lord uh do they
get now you say when they get older they
can attack a human they do but you know
surprisingly of all the big cat species
jaguars are the least likely to attack a
person even though they could and like i
said these guys are incredibly strong
their bites
are one of the strongest of all the big
cats and they could do some serious
damage but they never really attack
people which is good right
yes that is good
which is good right
i don't know do we want humans to be
attacked or not
okay look what you did you made it you
made a mess everywhere i hope you feel
terrible
i think they're done with their bottles
here okay they're absolutely uh
beautiful animals and it would be i
shouldn't keep this uh one as a pet
because they should not keep these guys
how long before my life would be in
danger seriously about six months old
then you wouldn't really be able to
handle them and i'm a pretty strong guy
and pretty fast when fighting cats yeah
i don't think so okay
this one's like i want to kill him now
i'm sorry that's all right we better go
this animal is a called a binturong
they're from southeast asia let's see if
she can
come on don't be lazy
she wants me to hold the banana for her
instead of holding it herself tell us i
don't even know what this animal what is
a binturong okay so this is a kind of an
animal it's like a made-up animal yeah
you know what they they kind of look
like a stroke can i pet it very gently
yeah why would it attack me or you know
what anything with a mouth can bite and
these guys actually have you know very
sharp teeth even though they like to eat
fruit this was not disgusting rehearsal
at all let's see you know anything to
get in the door so here we go okay all
right there we go now she's gonna eat
the banana so anyway this is an animal
called the civet they live in southeast
asia okay and um civ is a group of
animals that live in asia and africa so
most americans have never seen them
before oh but they kind of look like a
like something out of a dr seuss or
maybe jim henson's creature shop right
yes it doesn't even seem like a
plausible animal no offense to you but
would it where does the animal live and
what are its secret powers right so they
live they live in the tropics they can
trick you into peeling its bananas i
know right
what are its other secret powers
the biggest thing about it i don't know
if you can smell that they smell like
buttered popcorn yeah it's just we have
buttered popcorn here so it's just it's
just their natural odor okay and um you
know it's just they use that scent to
communicate with each other scent mark
and that kind of thing it just so
happens that it's a species that smells
like something good to us most animals
that smell like that so is it an
evolutionary trick in the dark to think
we're in a movie theater and then
attack us and tear us apart you know
what that would be really a really
clever way of you know surviving in our
modern world there's another uh his foe
can smell like a kitkat bar and trick us
into i haven't run across you you want
to feed a grape yeah sure what do i do
just gently kind of put like this oh
okay i thought there was a dream eat
that one all right yeah
what is it with me and the animals today
i love grapes here's one from conan
so these guys live in tropical forests
thank you